-Hello.
-You look gorgeous.
-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
-Thank you for having me.
It's always my favorite.
-I love that you're here
and I love that you come
on our show.
And I'm so -- I want to say --
I want to say congratulations
to you, you're newly engaged.
-I sure am.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes.
-Now, how was --
Tell me about the proposal.
Was it a surprise?
Was it planned?
-I secured the rock.
My work here is finished.
-Yes! You did it!
-I will just let myself go now.
No, um, well, I -- I wasn't
necessarily surprised
because I was like,
"Listen, you know,
I'm out here on the streets.
You gotta lock it down."
-Okay.
-I was like, dropping hints
left and right.
I was like, "Babe, wow my nails
look so good."
[ Laughter ]
And we went to Mexico
for the holidays
and he, I guess, set up
this whole grand thing
and then that fell through.
And so, on Christmas Eve,
he was setting up this dinner
on the balcony, but I thought
it was Christmas Eve dinner,
because I thought Christmas Eve
was reserved for baby Jesus.
So that was, I was like,
"Oh no, I --
it's probably not going to
happen tonight,"
and then it sure did.
-Wow.
-It sure did.
-You shared the evening
with baby Jesus.
-With tiny baby Jesus.
-Yes.
And -- [laughs] and you had
this beautiful dinner
and you go,
"Yeah, it's just perfect.
-It was amazing.
I'm so happy.
-And you told me that the ring
is very extra special to you.
Why?
-Yeah, so he worked
with this Vietnamese,
family-owned jeweler
from Canada -- Paris Jewelers --
to make it,
and he knows how
important my heritage is to me.
And he knows that paying
it forward
means a lot to me, as well.
And so, he worked with
these beautiful ladies there,
and I'm -- I'm so happy and
I -- Yeah, I can't believe it.
-I'm so happy to see that.
This is great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did you first meet?
-Well, we met at an Emmy party,
and I slid in,
I got his digits, and I --
as we were leaving I was like,
"Oh, hey, hey, hey.
Um, I thought of this joke,
but I forgot the punch line.
Can I have your number, and then
when I remember it later on,
I'll just text you."
And so that's how I got, yes --
-Wow, that's a good move.
-A smooth criminal.
And, yeah, so then I texted him
like 30 minutes later,
and I said, "Well, well, okay.
What do you call
a pile of kittens?"
-What do you call
a pile of kittens?
-A meow-ntain.
[ Light laughter ]
-A meow --
-A meow-ntain.
-And that's how you get
a fiance.
-There you go.
And that's exactly right.
It worked out perfect.
You know, it is Nana Week
here at the show.
Would you like to give
a shout-out to your grandma?
-Yes, my grandma loves
your show.
Um, so, hi, Grandma.
-Hi, Grandma!
-Look, it's my friend.
-Look, Lana is doing great,
Grandma.
-Thank you.
-We're giving you a big hug.
That's so good.
I wanna talk about your movie,
"Moonshot."
-"Moonshot." Oh, oh!
Cole really wishes he was here.
He sends his love.
-The funniest --
-He's the best.
-I love Cole Sprouse.
-Yes, he's awesome.
-He is a fun human being.
-It -- honestly? It was so much
fun to work with him.
It felt like --
we shot it last summer --
it felt just like we were at,
like, daycare, weirdly,
like, all --
every single day on set,
because we were always just
having so much fun,
and it's about basically
these two people
who are stuck in a spaceship
together,
traveling through space and time
to get to their loved ones.
So it's, like,
an adventure rom-com,
but, like, that's I feel like
not even a genre.
Like a feel, like, that's, like,
such a niche.
-You're starting a new genre.
-Like a sci-fi, weird, rom-com
is what it is.
So if that's your thing,
watch it.
-It's a sci-fi rom-com.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, this is brand new.
No one's seen anything like it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lana Condor
and Cole Sprouse in "Moonshot."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Initiating
ambient sound control.
♪♪
-Hey, you cannot
under any circumstances
leave my room, okay?
-What?
-I will sneak you in food,
there's a bathroom,
it'll be like...camping.
-Okay, clearly, you've never
gone camping before.
And I -- I'm not going to spend
my first trip
through space on the toilet.
-Because you prefer
the air ducts?
-Because what do you think
happens when two people
are trapped in the same room
together?
-When two humans are confined
for an extended period,
it results in either
more humans or fewer humans.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Well done.
Lana Condor, everybody.
"Moonshot" begins streaming
this Thursday on HBO Max.
We love you.
-Thank you for coming.
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations. So happy.
-Thank you.